[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN SHRIVER-BLAKE: Hello.
Welcome, everybody.
Thanks for coming out.
My name is John
Shriver-Blake, and I'm
a product manager for Firebase.
And I'll be joined later today
by Mike McDonald, who's also
a Firebase product manager.
And we're here today
to talk about building
enterprise-grade mobile
apps with Firebase.
You see, lots of people know
that Firebase is a great way
to build great apps.
And that helps you throughout
the lifecycle of your app
development process.
It can help you build your app.
With features like
Firestore, Cloud Storage,
and Authentication,
you can store and sync
data in the cloud
for your mobile app
without running your
own backend services.
You can then build on top
of that functionality using
Cloud Functions to run
backend code, once again,
without your own servers.
Finally, you can use Firebase
to help you take advantage of ML
in your app, using ML
Kit and both client
and cloud-side APIs.
Beyond building
your app, Firebase
can help you with
your app quality.
You can use Crashlytics to get
a real-time feed of your crashes
as they happen in the wild.
You can then use
Crashlytics to prioritize
and help fix those issues.
You can also get a clear idea
of your app's performance
and how it's being
perceived by your users,
and improve upon
your performance
with Firebase
Performance Monitoring.
Finally, you can run
tests for your app
on devices managed by Google
with Firebase Test Lab.
Beyond quality, we can
help you grow your app.
This starts with Google
Analytics for Firebase,
which gives you free
unlimited app analytics
so you can have a clear
understanding of what
your users are
doing in your app.
Once you have that
understanding,
you can then optimize
that experience
using A/B testing, Firebase
Cloud Messaging, and Remote
Config to really get
your users more engaged
and using more of your app.
Finally, we have
predictions, which
uses ML to analyze
your user's behavior
and creates custom groups so
you can then target those users.
For instance, there is a
custom group for retention
that will give you an idea of
users who are likely to churn.
You can then use notifications
or AB testing or Remote
Config to create specific
experiences for those users
to keep them from
churning out of your app.
There really is a lot that
Firebase has to offer.
The problem is many people
think that Firebase can't be
used in an enterprise setting.
And so I get
questions all the time
about security, compliance,
privacy, and production
readiness for Firebase.
And so today we're going to
answer some of those questions
and give you the information
that you need to get Firebase
deployed in your organization.
Specifically, we're going
to cover these three areas.
Is Firebase ready for
your organization?
Can you manage your
resources in Firebase
and control access in
the way that you need to?
Is Firebase ready
for your lawyers?
Will it meet your regulatory
and compliance requirements?
And finally, is Firebase
ready for production?
Will it scale?
Can you monitor it in
the way that you expect?
So first let's talk
about your organization.
Can you manage
and control access
to Firebase projects in
a way that you need to?
The answer is yes.
Firebase users can use Google
Cloud's enterprise-grade tools
to manage and control access
to Firebase resources, which
is great, right?
And this is possible because,
when it comes right down to it,
Firebase projects
are Cloud projects.
Now we in the Firebase
team have often
built tools to help users get
onto the Firebase platform
in an easy and simple way.
But underlying all of it
is Google Cloud Platform.
And so users who
want to can take
advantage of the more powerful
Google Cloud Platform tools
to perform more advanced
administrative scenarios.
Let's talk about some
of the tools the cloud
makes available for
this type of management.
The first is Google
Cloud Resource Manager.
This is your central way to
manage cloud and Firebase
resources within
your organization.
It gives administrators
the ability
to view all of the projects
and resources deployed
in their org, to
organize those projects
in a hierarchy of
folders, and then
assign access at the org,
folder, project, and resource
level.
Second is cloud identity.
This is your centralized
identity management solution
for cloud.
It allows you to manage
your users and groups,
and supports products like
single sign-on and two-factor
authentication so
you can be sure
that your users are having
both a safe and secure user
experience.
Finally is Cloud IAM, which is
Identity and Access Management.
This gives you
fine-grained access control
of who has access to what
in your organization.
You do this by assigning
roles to specific users
and groups that give them
limited access within Cloud.
For instance, there's a role
called App Engine Viewer
which gives users the ability to
view App Engine configuration.
Now this is a fairly broad role
so you might assign it fairly
broadly, let's say, to a group.
On the other hand, you might
reserve more of an edit role
to a smaller set of people.
Cloud IAM puts you in
that level of control.
Now those are predefined roles.
Something that Cloud IAM also
supports are custom roles.
And so if you find that the
predefined roles that we've
defined are not
sufficient for your needs,
you can get really
granular and create roles
with exactly the
permissions that you
need for your organization.
Finally, I want to mention
that all changes to IAM
are audited and logged so
that you can go back and get
a clear view of what changes
were made, when, and by whom
in your project.
Now those of you who are
familiar Firebase probably
know that today we don't
offer a lot of options
for fine-grained access
control with Firebase.
Well, good news--
rolling out now
is fine-grained access
control for Firebase.
This is actually
available to some of you
today, and will be
broadly available
by the end of the summer.
We've defined a set
of predefined roles
for Firebase users, like quality
admin or developer viewer, that
allow you to very easily give
people in Firebase access
to a limited subset
of the functionality.
In addition, we'll be
supporting custom roles.
So you can create your own roles
with exactly the permissions
that make the most sense
for your organization.
Now this is all rolling
out now, but I'm
going to give you a
preview of what it'll look
like so you've got a good idea.
OK, so here I am in
the Firebase console.
You can see I'm logged in as me.
And I want to go ahead and
give Mike access to my project
so that he can
send notifications.
So I'm going to
go into Settings,
and this brings up a
Firebase-specific user
management UI.
I'm going to go
ahead and add Mike.
There we go.
And I'm going to select a role.
And you can see in
the Role dropdown
there's the project level
roles that Firebase has always
supported.
But I can also give Mike
custom access to Firebase.
And somebody who's going to
wear shorts to a presentation,
I'm not so sure I trust
their professionalism.
So I'm going to lock down Mike
as much as possible by giving
him only grow admin access,
which means he can access
notifications but can't
access for instance
the contents of my database.
So there we go.
I'm going to add Mike.
Cool.
So let me switch over to Mike.
You can see here I am
logged in as Firebase Mike.
And because Mike has
grow admin access--
so if I go to Cloud
Messaging, you
can see he has full
read-write access.
But if I go to
Database, access denied.
He needs to ask a project owner
for the necessary permissions.
So I've been able
to grant access
Mike to only the things
that he needs, and I don't
have to worry about
him accessing things
that he shouldn't be.
Now some of you may be thinking
that these are a little too
coarse-grain for you.
And for those folks, you
can use custom roles.
So switching back to me,
once again logged in as me,
I'm going to go ahead and show
you how you do a custom role.
Now this is not something
that we support in our UI
because it's more of an
advanced user scenario.
So I'm going to go ahead and
click Advanced Permissions.
What this does is open up the
full Google Cloud Platform
console and the full
IAM experience there.
And if I go into
the flyout here,
you can see that
there's really a lot
of additional functionality
that's available here
for folks who want to
take advantage of it.
One of those things are roles.
So as I load this up,
you'll see there's
a long list of the
predefined roles.
But in addition to
those roles, I've
created a special
role just for Mike
that gives him
exactly the access
that he needs and nothing else.
So there's really a
lot of flexibility
here for those who need it.
Finally, I mentioned
audit login.
So I'm quickly move over to the
Google Cloud Platform activity
stream, which is a
central place to see
all of the administrative
actions that
have happened in your
organization, including IAM.
And it's a little slow.
It's the Wi-Fi.
I'm going to blame the Wi-Fi.
Here we go.
And there it is.
So not only do I
have a full activity
view of all of the
changes that have happened
in my organization, it
also reflects the change
that I just made.
Firebase John assigned Firebase
growth admin to Firebase Mike.
So I can get that full view
of all the changes happening
in my org, which is
super important to me
as a project administrator.
So going back to the deck,
the key takeaway for you
for this section is that you
can use the same powerful tools
available in Google
Cloud Platform
to manage and control access
to your Firebase resources.
So let's talk about our lawyers.
Anybody who's ever
deployed a new service
in a large organization
knows that it
can be a real challenge,
particularly because
of the lawyers.
If a service doesn't
meet your compliance
and regulatory needs, it can
be a complete nonstarter.
In addition, GDPR and other
emergent privacy regulations
have made it this
much more complicated.
We in Firebase want to
make this easier for you,
and we've been doing a
lot of work to that end.
And we're happy to say
that today Firebase
is ready to meet most
organization's compliance
needs, including
helping you in GDPR.
Now before I get
too much further,
I want to make
this really clear--
I am not a lawyer and
this is not legal advice.
If you haven't discussed some of
these topics with a lawyer yet,
I strongly suggest that you do.
GDPR.
So I had a interesting
experience this past winter.
I was at a water
park with my son,
and we were waiting
in this very long line
to get in the water park.
And all of a sudden,
a couple behind me
who also must have
worked together
started talking about GDPR.
And I could not understand
why they were talking
about GDPR at a water park.
And they were really
stressing out about it.
They were going on and on about
how much work they had to do,
how many open
questions they had,
and how hard it was to
get a straight answer.
And it was only later that I
realized that I was wearing
this T-shirt that says GDPR.
It turns out that
my GDPR T-shirt
ruined that couple's vacation.
I felt bad about that.
I worked on GDPR for
Firebase and I could relate.
It was a lot of work and
a fair amount of stress.
But with the benefit
of hindsight,
I've come to view it
as an opportunity.
It's an opportunity to
make sure that you're
doing the right thing for
your users and their privacy.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is how to implement best
practices for privacy
and how Firebase can
help you do that.
We're going to cover these three
specific areas that I think
many app developers have
challenges with and are
particularly important today.
One, are the
services that you're
using protecting your
user's data properly?
Two, do you have proper
consent flows for your users?
And three, are you giving
users transparency and control
that they need?
Let's talk about the first one.
It's almost
impossible these days
to build an app without relying
on third party services.
Many of you are probably
using Firebase, Google Cloud
Platform, and any number of
other services in your app.
If those services have
access to user data,
it's really important that
you have a clear understanding
of what data those
services are capturing,
how that data is
protected, and how
it's used by those services.
And it's on you as
the app developer
to ensure that all of that is
compliant with your privacy
policy, terms of service,
and consent experience.
How can Firebase help with this?
Well, first, in order to
help you be more confident
in Firebase's privacy
and security practices,
we've been working hard
to get industry standard
certifications for Firebase.
You can see that we already
have a bevy of ISO and SOC
certifications for
many Firebase products,
and we're continuing to
expand this constantly.
You can see just recently we
added ISO 27017 and ISO 27018
for Firestore.
And you'll see more of these
over the coming weeks, months,
and years.
In addition to third
party certifications,
something new at GDPR is
the concept of a DPST.
What a DPST is is a legal
agreement between you
and your service provider that
governs how they are protecting
and using your user data.
If you're subject to
GDPR, it's very important
that you have these in place
with all of your service
providers.
The good news is that Firebase
makes this really easy.
All Firebase services
are covered under a DPST,
and that DPST is
included by default
in our terms of service.
So if we're using our
products and you've
accepted our most recent terms,
you're covered under our DPSTs.
OK, consent flows.
I want to highlight
consent flows
because the standards for
consent flows are changing.
A consent flow that
was totally fine a year
or two ago may not be
fine under current norms.
And so if you haven't
reviewed your flows recently,
I strongly suggest that you do.
The overall goal
here is to make it
really clear to your users
what data you're are collecting
about them and how
you're going to use it,
and getting really clear consent
for that use from your users.
There's been a lot
of back and forth
about checkboxes versus buttons.
The main takeaway
here is that you
want to get really, really
clear consent from folks.
Now once you have
that experience right,
you're not quite done yet.
There's a few other things that
tend to trip up developers.
One is you need to be really
careful about what data you're
collecting before you have
consent from your users.
We see this all too often
where people accidentally
collect data that they shouldn't
be when their app starts,
for instance.
Be very careful that
you're not doing that.
Two, you need to make sure
that you're recording consent
in a way that you can prove it.
So if a regulator comes to
you down the road and says,
do you have consent
for user X, you
should be able to prove
that on your backend.
So how can Firebase help?
First, Firebase has
done a lot of work
to improve your control over
how data is collected and when.
We have a number of services
like Crashlytics and Analytics,
for instance, that by default
wake up when the app wakes up
and starts collecting data.
In some cases
that's totally fine.
In other cases you may decide
that you want to get consent
before that data is collected.
So it's now possible with
all Firebase services
that have this behavior to
change their default behavior.
So you can configure
them not to load on start
and activate them
programmatically
when you have consent and
you're ready to gather the data.
In addition, we've
published some example code
for notice and consent.
This includes UI for
how to get consent,
but also how to store
consent with Firebase
in a way that gives you
the tracking that you need.
This is available today
in our FriendlyPix app.
And for those of you aren't
familiar with FriendlyPix,
it's an open source app
for Android, iOS, and web
that shows you actually
a bunch of things
about how to build on Firebase.
So I strongly suggest
that you take a look
at that to get a better
idea of how to get
this critical experience right.
All right, finally,
are you offering users
transparency and
control of their data?
The key goal here is
that your users should
have clear visibility into
what data you have about them
and that they should be
in control of that data.
I've put up a screenshot here
from the Google My Activity
center, which I think is a
really good example of how
to do transparency control well.
This is available
to all Google users.
And when you log
in, it gives you
a detailed view of your usage
of Chrome, Search, Android,
and a bunch of other
developer tools.
It's really quite exhaustive.
You can see it includes
individual searches
that I've run on Google.
In addition to giving me
a lot of transparency,
it also puts me in control.
I can delete individual records,
I can delete data in bulk,
I can even export data for use
outside of Google services.
I think this is a really
good example of what we all
should be doing to provide
our users more transparency
and control.
So how does Firebase
help with this?
First, we've looked through
all of our applications
and all of our
services to make sure
that they have really
good delete support.
So that, for
instance, if you get
a request to delete a
specific user's data,
you can go through and delete
Crashlytics data or Analytics
data associated
with those users.
Some of our services didn't
have the best support there,
and that's all been
updated recently
to ensure that you can
be compliant with GDPR.
In addition, we've published
an export and deletion
guide that demonstrates
how to properly handle
user deletion and user export
for apps built on Firebase.
It's actually really
quite powerful and simple
using the power of
Cloud Functions,
and so I'm going to walk you
through a little bit of how
that works.
Before I do, I want to
mention that this all up
on GitHub in the Firebase
repository under User Privacy.
It's open source, so you
can grab it today and start
using it in your apps.
So I mentioned we're going to
use Cloud Functions in order
to do this stuff.
And what's great
about Cloud Functions
is the flexibility you
have in terms of when
functions are kicked off.
In this case, we're going to
take advantage of the fact
that Firebase authentication
is an event emitter.
And so you can see at
the top of this code
we're keying off of
functions.auth.user.ondelete.
What this means is that
when a Firebase auth
user gets deleted, this function
will get called and then clean
up the rest of the data.
Now this is really
very flexible.
You can also rely on an HTTP
request to kick this off.
You can even use our client-side
SDK to kick off this function.
Once it's initiated,
this function basically
just goes through and calls
wipeout calls for each one
of our services in Firebase.
So let's go ahead and look
at the database wipeout call.
Once again, fairly
simple function.
What this does is it loads in a
number of paths from a config,
and then iterates
through those paths,
deleting each one of
them from the database.
But where does the
paths come from?
Well, they're over here
in user_privacy.json.
You can see here I specified
two paths, users and admins,
both in this case keyed
off of the user ID.
So I can know that when
my auth user gets deleted,
the data at these two paths
will also get deleted.
This also works
for other services,
and I've included an
example of how this would
work in storage further down.
So there it is.
With a few simple
functions, I can
rest assured that
when my Firebase auth
user gets deleted, their data
is out of my system as well.
So the key takeaway for
you is that Firebase
has done a lot of
work to make sure
that we can meet the compliance
and regulatory needs of most
organizations, and that
we've done a lot of work
to help you be
compliant with GDPR.
And with that, I'm
going to hand it over
to Mike, who is going to talk
about taking your Firebase
app to production.
MICHAEL MCDONALD: Thanks, John.
OK, so John just
showed functions code
that needs to get
deployed somewhere.
He showed databases
and storage buckets.
How do we know that
that code is actually
going to scale once
it's out in production?
And once it's out there, how do
we know that John didn't just
copy those blindly
from a GitHub repo
and deploy them and
assume that they work?
We need to verify that our
functions aren't crashing,
that code is actually
running and doing
what we think it will.
And lastly, we have to
make sure that we're not
breaking the bank.
We don't want someone
from finance crawling up
into our cubicle
and saying, you're
spending way too much money,
you need to shut that down.
Because that's a critical
part of your business.
So let's tackle
those individually.
Because Firebase is
built on top of Cloud,
it can both scale to meet
those incredible needs
of your organization.
But with tools like
Functions and serverless,
we're also making sure that
we can do it economically.
So we'll start with scale.
A lot of Firebase features like
Cloud Firestore, Cloud Storage,
and Cloud Functions,
as the name implies,
are built on top
of Google Cloud.
So you can use the
Firebase client
SDKs and our really,
really nice console
to maximize developer
productivity.
And then if you
need to do things
like automate the creation
of storage buckets
or create different environments
for all of your functions,
you can also use the
power of the various tools
that Google Cloud
provides in order
to supercharge and provide
the granular customizability
that you need.
One of the other
things because of that
is that a lot of Firebase
services like those
are available in other regions.
So Cloud Storage,
for instance, you
can create buckets in
all of these regions.
And actually it's
probably out of date
because I bet we probably just
launched new regions today
or sometime in the recent past.
We have a ton of
different regions,
so can you meet either
compliance needs or performance
needs.
If you have users in
Australia, for instance,
you might want to have
buckets in Australia
to meet either the Australian
data locality requirements
or just simple performance.
Along that line, today
or in the recent past
or in the near future,
Cloud Functions
will be offering
regionality support.
So you can actually
take your functions
and deploy them exactly
where your users are.
You can just type in --region
and deploy to whatever region.
This will be coming
for Cloud Firestore
as well in the future.
So we've deployed all of
our various resources.
How do we know that those
resources are actually doing
what we say they're doing?
So that's where
Stackdriver comes in.
So Stackdriver is not only
Google's monitoring solution,
but it will also do alerting,
it will do error reporting.
Basically, it's
the one-stop shop
for your operational needs.
Firebase has a number of
integrations with Stackdriver.
So you can take a look
at the various cloud
integrated services and see
which pieces of Stackdriver
are currently included.
So a ton of things
kick out metrics
to Stackdriver monitoring.
And therefore you can alert
based on changes to those.
And then Cloud Functions
provides really nice logging
and error reporting
that I'll demo later.
So we'll show it right now, and
then we'll demo it in a minute.
But John went and deployed
a bunch of functions.
FriendlyPix, I
think, actually has
about 15 different
functions running
in the background for everything
from cleaning up user accounts
after they've been
deleted to it's
a pictures on the internet app.
So what are people going to
post on the internet-- horrible,
horrible ridiculous content.
So we actually have a function
that runs the Cloud Vision API,
and it will pull in the photo,
do an NSFW or inappropriate
content filtering on
it, and then decide
whether or not to moderate it.
And again, that's a
business critical thing.
So look up here, make sure
that nothing is erroring out.
And on the case that
something is erroring out,
we can actually dive into
Stackdriver Error Reporting
and take a look at exactly
what error is occurring.
So if you notice here,
we can see things
like permission denied.
I couldn't write to the database
because something happened.
Or you can actually see,
if you look at mine,
that I don't know how
to program JavaScript.
And so I got a bunch of
crazy JavaScript errors
that are basically
just like, hey, Mike
doesn't know how to program.
But you can start doing things
like opening or closing those
or acknowledging them that
someone is working on it,
and track that.
So we'll demo that
right at the end.
So we've verified
logs are looking good.
We're getting hopefully
no errors showing up
in error reporting.
Now we want longer
term monitoring.
So we want to make
sure that the cloud is
up and still responding.
But we also may
want to know things
like how much data is being
added to our storage bucket.
So how many pictures
are being added per day.
I want to know because finance
has told me that I can only
spend $100 a month on this app.
I want to start making
sure that I'm not
storing more than 100
gigabytes of data.
I can use Stackdriver monitoring
to start setting alerts
and understanding, maybe
put up a big dashboard
for the entire team to see
what growth looks like,
and start sending
alerts based on that.
A bunch of different Firebase
products offer a ton, a ton,
a ton of different
metrics on this.
And as I mentioned, you can
then, through Stackdriver,
to start dashboarding
these things.
So this is a dashboard that
I built for FriendlyPix
that has data stored.
So I set a five gigabyte alert.
So five gigabytes I think is
the free-tier limit for storage.
So I said, hey, I want to
draw a line across that
and make sure that
I'm not getting close,
and then set up an
alert based on that.
Similarly, I want to track
other key metrics like bandwidth
or requests coming into
the database in storage.
And as I said, I can
then set up policies
based on those metrics.
So this is my alert
for five gigabytes.
So you can see--
let me know any
time the total bytes
metric is above five gigabytes
for more than one minute.
And I will send that
email to Firebase Mike.
Though I could if I
wanted to, and actually
have services running that
send me really annoying text
messages if my "Minecraft"
server goes down,
just to make sure that
everything is up and running.
And these alerts are
actually great because you
can add markdown documentation.
So for instance,
maybe you already
have a playbook
for your service.
You can actually drop that
playbook documentation directly
into it.
So whenever I get an
email where my "Minecraft"
server goes down, it actually
has exactly the three steps
that I usually just
have to copy and paste--
because I haven't automated it--
directly into SSH into the
machine, fix it, and I'm done.
So you get everything there.
And then you get
another email saying,
hey, we've cleaned up the issue,
everything is good to go again.
And this is actually an
exact example of that right
where you see, hey,
"Minecraft" server is failing.
Right down at the bottom we
have the policy documentation
that is literally just, hey,
make sure the VM is still
running, mount
whatever appropriate
disks, et cetera, et cetera.
And then when it's
fixed, you can see, hey,
the violation is ended,
everything is all clear.
The last thing, we
talked about all
of those finance people
cropping up in unexpected times
right when your service
is on its stellar growth.
You need to make sure
that, one, you can estimate
the cost of your service.
So we've provided
cost calculators
through both Firebase
and Google Cloud
to understand, hey, maybe
you're building a chat app
and you want to send a
certain number of messages
or you're storing a
certain number of pictures.
We can let you
slide around and see
approximately what
it's going to cost
to run on our infrastructure.
And because you want to
ensure that once your thing is
running, you're not going
to just completely blow
your budget away,
you can actually
start setting budget alerts.
So I set a budget
alert here that I
don't want to spend
any more than $50
a month running my
"Minecraft" server.
So I set at 50%, send me an
alert at 90% and at 100%,
send me an email that just
says, hey, Mike, FYI, you're
coming up on your budget alert.
And one of the things John and
I were actually talking right
before this talk, we've created
this fun meta recursive system
where you can actually
have billing alerts trigger
functions that would
then let you say shut off
resources, which is fun
because those functions also
cost money.
And it would end up
in this weird world
where who knows what
you could end up doing.
But that's the system that
we're trying to build.
We're giving you all the tools.
And then in Firebase
we're working
to automate that
and orchestrate it
to give you really the control
you need at a high level.
So let's switch
over to the demo.
And I will actually show you
by building a couple of things
how this all works.
So here we're looking at
the backend for FriendlyPix.
And hopefully everyone can see
that in the back of the room.
But you can see a bunch
of logs that we have,
and you can start
seeing things like,
oh, we're getting some warning.
So maybe I want to
actually dive into that,
and we can just
search for warning.
And I can say, load more
logs, load older logs,
scroll through, et cetera.
And there are actually a ton
of things that give out logs.
So I can for instance look
at various audited resources
and say, hey, I want to know
everything calling the Vision
API, or I want to know all of
the changes that have been made
to the Google OAuth Client ID.
And a bunch of that
information also shows up.
And if I want, I could also dive
into say particular functions.
And maybe I know that
one of these functions
is being problematic--
I want to look for logs on that.
Not only can I filter
by doing arbitrary text,
I can filter by any of
these other columns.
Maybe only give me critical
errors in all functions,
and hopefully in the
last hour there have not
been any critical errors.
Though we'll let it load and
see if that is actually true.
If there are, I recommend
deleting FriendlyPix.
No.
There you go.
So nothing is horribly broken
in FriendlyPix right now.
And if it was-- so actually
we did this talk at I/O
and we were having
errors, so I immediately
added all sorts of alerting.
And now the
developers get pinged
whenever anything happens.
And so clearly they have fixed
all the bugs in FriendlyPix
because of that.
So speaking of those alerts,
I'll actually pop open to some
that I've resolved or muted.
We'll see, I thought
I had some more.
I guess everything is going
well because we only have one.
So we can dive in
and we can see, hey,
we've been failing to
send notifications.
We can actually see the entire
stack trace of, hey, here's
the JavaScript code.
So you can see--
where is it-- yeah, a bunch
of server errors, whatever.
A message targeted to an
I/O desk device cannot be--
so it's an APNS
certificate issue.
So now that's given us all
the things that we need
to then go and fix the problem.
You can also see
all of the instances
when this has happened,
as well as this
will have time correlations.
So you can see, hey, maybe
this only started two days ago.
Is there something that we
did in our infrastructure
two days ago that
made this occur?
And then when you're
done, you can say, hey,
I have acknowledged
that this is the case.
Say you're using GitHub and
someone has filed an issue,
you can stick in GitHub issue
tracking or Jira or whatever
tool you're using and
acknowledge it there.
So you have this other
tracking built in.
Over to the dashboards.
So this was the
dashboard that we
saw earlier that showed the
five gigabyte storage threshold.
You can see both Database and
Cloud Storage storage, as well
as bandwidth storage, et cetera.
So I would actually
add another one.
I want to start tracking
those function invocations.
So we had six or
seven functions.
I want to know which
ones are being called.
Is there any correlation
between them?
Maybe if something
happens, I want
to know if one of those
functions is going haywire.
So I'll add another chart.
And so we'll just call
that functions executions.
And we'll say Cloud Functions,
and there's an execution metric
that tells us count of
Cloud Functions, executions
broken down by status.
And so you can
actually see, we have
a ton of different functions.
For instance, how much
memory each function is using
and how many times
they're being invoked?
I only care about filtering
by the function name.
But I could say, oh, I want to
know functions in this region
and maybe measure
their latency and see
if the functions
in a certain region
are faster or slower than
functions in another region.
But for now, we'll just
group them by function name
and do the sum.
I only care about
the total number
of functions being executed
potentially across all regions
or regardless of status code.
But I may want to say, only
give me functions that succeed
or only give me
functions that fail.
So we'll save that, and
we can see immediately
we get that new dashboard.
Nope, that's only
for the past day.
We could also start
doing historical things.
So I'd actually already loaded
that, so it's pretty quick.
But this is the past week
of function executions.
So I can scroll through there.
Again, we're not seeing
terribly interesting things.
Maybe in the past
month we'll see--
so you can see a
couple of spikes.
I'm curious around I/O
or when we launched this
if there was some more spikes.
But OK, so this would
be a great dashboard
that you could set
up for your team.
And the last thing would be
setting up an alerting policy.
So I have a couple of pretty
simple alerting policies.
So I have one that says, anytime
storage is over five gigabytes.
But I also have a couple of
other more interesting ones.
For instance, let me know if the
number of objects in my storage
bucket has doubled
in the past 12 hours.
And that could
indicate, hey, maybe
my app really got
popular on the app store.
It gives you this
heads up of maybe I
need to start different
financial planning
or just maybe our marketing
team has done something that
may affect our infrastructure.
So I'll create another alert.
We have a simple one for
storage being over quota.
I will copy that and
create one for the database
and do a similar thing.
I want to know when--
let's pull it up.
And the resources will use when
the real-time database is--
so we can do-- and
the real-time database
has a ton of different metrics,
but we'll do bytes stored.
And the condition, if it is
above, and we'll do one--
let's try it-- I think that
should be one gigabyte,
because it's all in bytes--
for more than one minute.
And we will save that condition.
And then as you can see, I can
start adding notifications.
I can actually send
it to the mobile app.
I could SMS myself.
I could send it to
a Slack channel.
We'll trying to meet you
wherever you are as a team.
For now, we'll just
send it to email.
Again, I could add some docs.
I don't really know
what to do here.
Maybe this is, send an email
to someone to let them know.
Who knows?
And we'll call this database
over quota threshold.
And we'll save that policy.
And we'll go back.
Cool.
We have that policy,
and you can see.
I have not unfortunately
found a great way
to start triggering these,
because obviously it
takes a little bit.
And for instance, storage
isn't monetized immediately.
But you have to trust me--
I get these emails all the time.
They're fantastic.
I will show one other thing.
I will pop over to
the Billing tab.
And I don't actually
know if I can do that.
I'll switch projects
and show you a billing
account in a different project.
I like how it shows it and
then immediately-- there we go.
So I do have a billing
account for here,
and I will show
you billing alerts.
So go to the Linked
Billing Account.
So I can set up a budget that
is my $50 a month spend limit.
And you can see that trigger
alerts at 50%, 90%, and 100%.
And you can see there that
I've used $7.68 out of $10.
Oh, I ramped it down.
We'll actually call
that a $10 a month
spending limit
linked to a project.
I can say, hey, target it to
last month's spend and let me
know if I'm above
last month's spend,
which was I guess $10.60.
Or I could enter maybe I'm going
to bump it up and call it $15.
Note how it autocalculates too.
So I can add just a percent.
Maybe notify me at
150% of my budget
just in case I keep going over.
And as John mentioned,
you can connect this up
to a Pub/Sub topic.
You can get fed
into Functions so
that you can start
turning resources off
or to other things.
So we'll save it.
And if I set it below
I could get an email
and prove it to you there.
But you won't do that.
Nope, other way.
Back to slides.
So John talked
about Firebase being
ready organizationally and
from a legal and compliance
standpoint.
And then I talked about
productionization, scaling,
monitoring, alerting,
understanding the finances
of your application.
So yes, at this point
we believe that Firebase
is ready for the needs
of large organizations.
There's still a lot to work on.
But as we integrate deeper
with Google Cloud Platform,
we'll keep getting more of the
compliance, more regionality,
more awesome monitoring and
scaling and budgeting alerting
through Google Cloud.
So thank you,
everyone, for coming.
We'll be around after for
questions, if you have them.
Otherwise, enjoy
the rest of Next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]